puis en bref cette plainte déposée par
les avocats des manuels macron à
l'encontre d'un homme à l'origine d'un
photomontage montrant le président de la
république grimé en adolf hitler affublé
d'une petite moustache vous le voyez sur
cette image obéi et fais-toi vacciner
cette photo a été placardée sur des
panneaux d'affichage à toulon et à la
seyne-sur-mer l'avocat du suspect
confirme par ailleurs que son client est
convoqué par la justice ce jeudi l'homme
a déjà été condamné par le passé alors
mis ses lampions et merci d'être avec
nous alors le président la république a
porté plainte contre vous c'est quoi
dans la vie jean louis michel en une
seconde vainqueur à ma petite fille qui
m'a demandé marriott reviendra soit fois
très bien alors vous faites quoi dans
l'est je suis à fischer d'accord je dis
pas publicitaire car nous avions une
société sur la cote que nous avons vendu
leurs cinq ans maintenant j'ai conservé
deux panneaux les chemins sert pour
twitté maintenant depuis quelques années
ils sont très connus chez nous dans le
hall pourquoi vous avez coller ses
affiches tir touche énormément parlé
bien écouter ça fait quelques années
donc je vous dis
cyril moi il serait nommé c'est patrick
tout notre
oui d'accord donc cyril ça fait quelques
années que j'affiche
des affiches qui me permet d'entrer dans
le débat public vous saviez vous alliez
choqué en faisant ça parce que c'est
quand même c'est c'est quand même elle
en pierre c'est quand tu vois ses
affiches ça moi je leur profondément
choquée je trouve ça soit
pour vous l'avez fait écoutez je fais ça
depuis longtemps je comprends que des
gens soient choqués mais c'est le propre
de liberté d'expression tout le monde
peut pas être d'accord avec vous moi je
me suis inspiré pour le portrait la vue
du musée de cire à londres tussauds oui
je les nie aucune on m'a dit oui vous
l'avez assimilé dans la plainte emmanuel
macron dit que je lai assimilés non je
les grilles mais
comprenez que le président de la
république on aime vous êtes choqués
quoique quai de voir ça aussi cette
norme pour sa famille ces termes on
avait pensé à sens pas du tout vous
dédie mon nom je pense que c'est une
caricature vous savez moi je regardais
un tweet de millas il ya quelques
semaines elle disait je voulais
guillemets je n'ai toujours pas enlevé
euh mon doigt du cul du prophète on a
renforcé la police autour d'elle est en
droit de le dire mais c'est choquant
pour des millions des dizaines ou des
centaines de millions de personnes donc
j entends pas les bons esprits là à
protester contre ce que 10000 1 et quand
charlie hebdo publie des caricatures
avec le cul de mahomet est exposée mais
aussi à des gens qui croient dans cette
religion moi personnellement je suis
pour la liberté d'expression totale et
donc après la décapitation du
pauvre professeur la samuel pâtit j'ai
vu emmanuel macron s'ouvrir sur la
chaîne al jazira c'est à dire donner des
leçons au monde entier en particulier au
monde arabe et en particulier à erdogan
et au qatari en expliquant que chez nous
on pouvait tout dire tout écrire tout
dessiné tout caricaturer c'était la
liberté ou bien me démontre que c'était
un discours de dupes
manuel macron c'est le en même temps
vous voulez vous voyez choqué dit
évidemment une caricature c'est fait
pour grossir le trait et sinon tu n'en
parlez vous vous aviez vraiment des
convictions écoutez moi ça fait
longtemps que les gens qui sont chez
nous là bas connaissent mais affichage
j'ai pas besoin ça me rapporte rien ça
me coûte puisque les avocats c'est quand
même moi qui les payent
je fais face à l'as en jugement quand le
17 septembre et le procureur a trouvé de
date parce que vous savez la justice est
indépendante en france mais dès qu'il
s'agit de quelqu'un de puissant elle
s'active rapidement donc mi août le bleu
le procureur de toulon monsieur marshall
sans appel une série télévisée de ma
jeunesse donc à trouver une date le 17
septembre pour plaider deux affaires
donc c'est assez savary ce qui me masser
une injure publique au président la
république ses 12000 euros d'amendé au
maximum d'accord il y en a qui a cliqué
choqué jean pierre tsunami toi tu toi tu
comprends que pour le président et puis
je connais je voudrais rammer revenir à
ce que disait valérie bénaïm tout à
l'heure on peut pas dire c'est bien
c'est malsain justice ne veut faire
pratt whitney de décider de supprimer un
contre c'est pas à nous de juger c'est
un juge et c'est pour ça que c'est bien
qu'ils aient une plainte là dessus at il
enfreint la loi je pense que oui mais on
verra bien on voit que c'est toi de toi
jean pierre tu comprends que le
président ait porté plainte évidemment
oui je crois la dernière plainte s'était
pas de gaulle c'était pompidou je crois
il y avait une plainte
c'est de gaulle georges pompidou qui
avait été pris en photo sur un bateau et
qui avait porté plainte parce que c'est
la première fois qu'on voyait un
président de la république en bateau et
à l'époque où on osait par kiki qu'il
comprend michele oui bah certes l'image
elle est choquante mais elle n'est pas
gratuite en fait derrière l'image et un
message ce message il est clair c'est
qu'aujourd'hui il ya des millions de
français qui ont la sensation de vivre
dans une dictature donc certes c'est
violent à distance sur la sensation j'ai
dit deux villes internet à turin ce
temps quand même qu'ils ont la sensation
est clair c'est violent mais je pense
que c'est à la hauteur de l'exaspération
de millions de français qui ont en marre
qu'on leur vole leur liberté c'est de
venir ici là il a porté plainte pour
diffamation publique le chef de l'état
vous olive olives ou beaucoup reçu
monsieur insultes et diffamation
publiques aux siens non mais c'est vrai
que tu es d'accord c'est pas retenu bah
moi je rejoins un petit peu ce qu'a été
dire c'est une caricature si on interdit
ça on ferme charlie hebdo de nuit pour
moi c'est clair et net je pense que on a
l'image d'un sinistre personnage de
l'histoire ça c'est une certitude mais
je pense que personne pour ses boucles
oui après est-ce que vous si vous aviez
été représentée comme ça est-ce que mais
je parle pas forcément des manuels ma
prime je parle bien sûr pas mal non mais
vous est ce que vous auriez été choqué
ce que vous auriez l'âme et la même
horreur avec soin mais je pense que
quand on en arrive là il faut se
remettre en question c'est qu'il ya un
problème dans notre pays s'il ya des
gens qui veulent choquer aujourd'hui je
vous le répète on a eu un sinistre
personnage dans l'histoire du monde et
personne ne pourra revenir là dessus et
aujourd'hui on a sinistre personnage
dans notre pays parce que à côté de ça
on voit ça mais il faut quand même lire
ce qui a marqué à coder obéi c'est toi
vacciner pourquoi parce qu'on n'entend
pas assez parlé tout ça le 15 septembre
il ya des centaines de milliers de
personnes qui vont perdre leur emploi
que ça soit des infirmières des pompiers
des gendarmes des chauffeurs des gens
qui travaillent dans des bars dans des
restaurants et eux ils sont vraiment au
plus bas au plus bas on entend quand on
entend parler discuter sans aller
applaudir par exemple c'est ridicule de
devoir avoir un pas de sanitaires pour
les jo ne le fait pas de passes
sanitaire dans le métro mais je pense
que la smart capture et là je suis
choquée j'en ai pas lâché justement faut
pas choquer faut discuter dans ce moment
faut discuter mais père jean silva
conquis à l écoute de la discussion
aujourd'hui on est géré de façon normale
mais pas au point
alors tu n'as pas les personnels géré
attaqueront et avec verlan en fait c'est
pareil dans tous les pays monsieur
jacques chirac s'y met mais s'il n'y a
pas de passe à dix heures partout mais
surveille moi j'étais en y incluant des
talibans
classés que moi si je me fais vacciner
c'est pas pour plaire à maquereau s'ils
veulent accéder ou si je mens pas
sanitaire c'est pas pour faire les yeux
doux aveyron j'en ai rien à [ __ ] je
suis d'accord avec vous j'ai envie et je
pense peut-être que je me trompe mais je
pense que c'est la meilleure solution
batterie les épaules et c est ce qu on
peut laisser les gens qui n'ont pas
envie de se faire vacciner aujourd'hui
est libre et comment sa tante liberté
des droits de l'homme est ce qu'on peut
les laisser libres donné mais en on nous
a expliqué pendant un an et demi que le
vaccin était la solution est maintenant
on explique à des non vaccinés qu'il
faut qu'ils vaccinent pour protéger les
vacciner pour
fabrice des vidéos s'il est choqué par
ce qu'a fait michael michel ange je
crois que ja il ya deux débats comme
toujours on fait jean pierre pernaut a
dit quelque chose d'intéressant ya un
débat juridique est ce que monsieur
enfreint la loi ça c'est le tribunal qui
décidera à quelque part c'est pas assez
pas à nous dire s'ils ont enfreint la
loi sur la question de savoir parce que
finalement la vraie question c'est est
ce que le président de la république a
eu raison de déposer plainte ou pas il a
le droit de le faire il l'a fait
maintenant il ya un autre débat c'est en
fait jusqu où la liberté c'est compliqué
comme question parce que finalement au
bate oif été vaccinées grimée en hitler
c'est pas très heureux mais finalement
par rapport il le disait olibeau libre
par rapport à charlie où on le fixe
l'esprit charlie jusqu'où ils s'arrêtent
jusqu'où y va on voit bien que la
question n est pas évidente moi ce qui
me perturbe c'est que quand on est
président de la république que
finalement on fait le choix de cliver
parce qu'il le savait accès parce
sanitaire peu importe qu'on en pense et
chacun sait ce que j'en pense d'ailleurs
mais le problème se pose pas en ces
termes il a fait le choix de dresser une
partie de la population contre l'autre
il a fait le choix du choc oui mais en
répond en réponse qu'est ce qu'il a il a
effectivement un usage de la liberté qui
choque qu'est-ce qui fait et bien il
vient du coup s'offusquer et déposer
plainte ça marche pas ça ne marche pas
c'est pas comme ça que ça fonctionne